welcome back to CBS this morning after
this week's public testimony House
Democrats tell CBS News they do have
enough evidence to move forward with
articles of impeachment against the
president yesterday lawmakers heard from
the last of 12 scheduled witnesses
former White House official fiona hill
said she believes EU Ambassador Gordon
Gordon Sunland was used to push the
president's personal political agenda
getting Ukraine to open investigations
into the Biden's and the 2016 election
I've actually realized having listened
his deposition that he was absolutely
right
that he wasn't coordinating with us
because we weren't doing the same thing
that he was doing he was being involved
in a domestic political arrant and we
were being involved in national security
foreign policy and those two things had
just diverged the White House says
President Trump is looking forward to
laying out his case in a Senate trial
should he be impeached in the house the
president met with several top
Republican senators yesterday to discuss
the next steps in the process Jonathan
Turley and Kim Whaley are CBS News legal
analysts and constitutional scholars and
they join us now to explain where the
impeachment inquiry is headed next so
Kim let's start with you did the
Democrats lay out a case that was strong
enough to reach that constitutional bar
for impeachment well if the question is
abuse of power yes they absolutely did
and that the president
it looks like asked for an investigation
or announcement of investigations into a
political rival in exchange for release
of military aid so using the power of
the presidency the ability to have a
White House meeting to release this
critical aid that Ukraine needed to
stave off Russian aggression and said
you know what you have to help me
personally so that is the standard that
the framers cared about having somebody
in office that would use that power for
themselves not for the benefit of the
American people and here we know it was
a contrary to national security so as
far as you're concerned write out the
articles of impeachment let's vote
tomorrow we're gonna see it as far as
let's vote for to vote tomorrow no and
the process is a Senate trial and we'll
have to see what's in the article so
then test the evidence against those
those claims Jonathan do you feel the
same I'm afraid I don't the fact is they
this is the but certainly the shortest
investigation it's certainly the
thinnest evidentiary record and it's the
narrowest impeachment ever to go to the
Senate if they were to go on this record
I what they did is they did show a quid
pro quo came and I agree with that I
think they had powerful witness that the
witnesses were really marvelous and they
go why don't they have a case well
because the question is do they did they
prove something was contemptible or
impeachable contemptible is not
synonymous with impeachable the
president does set policy they have
three conversations two of them directly
one with you senator Johnson one with
ambassador Sundlun where Trump denies a
quid pro quo I think you can toss the
Sundlun one out because that's September
9th he knew about the whistleblower but
the senator Johnson one was August 31st
so you have a conflicted record and the
question is what do you need to remove a
sitting president except we do have the
call transcript right what why haven't
the Democrats the Democrats subpoenaed
john bolton which would take them into
the White House but they haven't pushed
to get him into the hearings why not I
don't know I whether this is intentional
or not it seems designed to fail in the
Senate I don't think you could prove a
removable offense of a president on this
record even if the Democrats were in
control this thing is too narrow it is
it doesn't have a broad foundation and
it's an undeveloped record there are a
lot of Wick or witnesses that were not
called and the question is why they said
we want to vote by December you know we
want to vote before Santa why why why
why would you why would you be pushing
this instead of calling these critical
with one quick thing mr. Bolten just
tweeted he said for the backstory stay
tuned
what does that mean I mean no but but
this is the thing I wonder what the
American people are thinking we've had
17 witnesses you point out many of them
stellar stellar reputations and partisan
3,000 pages of sworn depositions I think
people's eyes start to glaze over
Ukraine where is it some people would
say what is this is it bribery is a clue
what is it what do you think is really
at stake here Kim what's at stake here
is the separation of powers we don't
have a single person or branch in charge
we're not a monarchy the idea is every
branch gets
their papers graded by the other two
brands and say about the office of the
presidency office of the presidency if
wrongdoing in the office abuse of power
is not checked then we enlarge the
office the belt-and-suspenders of the
power of the presidency gets enlarged
that gets passed on to the next
president to the next president to
future generations and it won't always
be this particular president or even
this particular political party Jonathan
Reince Priebus said earlier today if
this when this gets if this gets to the
Senate when it gets the Senate the rules
are changing they are and the other
Senate the Republicans will be in charge
of the rules I was Adam Schiff supposing
Council last time we did this in the
last impeachment and I Adam benefited
greatly because the Democrats were the
ones that wrote those rules now it's
going to be the opposite even the chief
justice in that proceeding does not get
the final word if he makes a ruling on
evidence the majority of the Senate can
overturn him and so the question is what
is this gonna look like in the Senate
and I got to tell you I think that this
could be at the trial the Trump wants
and they will the first witness they
call maybe hunter Biden well hope it's
as civil as it was in the house because
so far the process has been I think very
measured and and thoughtful and
professional which is good we'll all
still be watching Republicans storming
the basement Thank You Kimmy and
Jonathan Turley always good to have you
both here